Am I dead?
Why does my eyes hurt?
(I've never used this before)
The rules
of the internet
Yes, it does exists
It's cringy as fuck, someone actually wrote this shit
Rule #1
There are no girls on the internet
It's actually true
Do not talk about /b/
I'm not gonna read the rest of it
But there is one rule in particular that is still relevant to this day
I'm talking of course
About rule 34
There is porn of it, no exceptions
So basically, if I would say something outrageous,
like, pterodactyls
Those fucking dinosaurs with the wings
OK let's search
You know what? Why not?
Pterodactyl porn
Wait what the fuck is this?
There's a video
2 millions views that's... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
That was just a joke!
I didn't think they would actually oh my god no! God! God dammit! Fuck!
Who would accept this?
Pterodactyls man!
They used to be my favourite dinosaur!
needless to say, don't flag this fucking video, just because of this, alright?
ya'll just flag every video, even though I censor it!
the joke of this video was supposed to be
that I'm gonna search something, it's not gonna show up
so we're gonna make it
now there is this website, that uh, a friend
A friend told me about this one, I haven't heard of it
It's uh, Rule 34
So basically,
Let's say if I would show, type PewDiePie here
There should technically
*Burps*
Oh my god what the
What...The...Fucking shit god damn it
Why am I always the bottom bitch?
Okay, alright, god, I can't
Alright I'm gonna come up with something so crazy,
There's not gonna be porn of it, we're gonna make it.
We're gonna draw our own.
Alright let's think here...
* ALL THE HARD WORK, THAT WENT INTO IT*
SNICKERS
There's no fucking way, there is Snickers porn
Oh my fucking god.
Oh my god.
Why.
WOW!! AMERICAN SNACKS ARE HUGE!! I LOVE BIG AMERICAN COCK-OLATE!
LAMPS
Ain't nothing sexual about lamps.
Oh my god
Of course, how the-
How did I not see that
What about a CD?
What--
* death of soul laughter *
God damn it.
what about a SHOPPING CART!
Ain't nothing sexual about a shopping cart.
Oh for FUCK'S SAKE!
ok what if- we gotta think deeper
if we're gonna beat this game, we gotta think deeper
now what possibly could not be sexualized
think with me, HELP GOD DAMN IT!
HELP ME GOD DAMN IT!
Of course
Something that is already sexual
Butts
C'mon
C'MON
* THE WAIT *
YESSSSSSSSSS!
I BEAT YOU!
SO NOW, we're gonna make our own
Mmkay
Alright so here we go
Man that's hard to...
draw
okay , so we got a butt here
have a nice
he has a nice
uhh
SUIT
popping home from work
i'm drawing a clevage on a butt
this is great
does the butts have butts?
* QUESTION OF THE MILLENIUM! *
yeah, yeah they, they must have butts
okay well there you go
we filled an empty hole of the internet today
Should all be proud
What about boobs?
Oh my GOD, WE FOUND A LOOPHOLE!
okay
uhhh
* ALL THAT HARD WORK & DETAILING *
look at that they love each other
oh god why
Okay I got it
Car
Ain't nothing sexual about that
HOLY FUCKING SHIT-I was wrong
Now what in everything HOLY-THE FUCK IS THIS?
* NEEDS TO CHILL *
I wanna die
Alright what about this
CONTINENTS
What the fuck... DON'T TURN SWEDEN INTO A PENIS!
And a snail.... IS THAT A SNAIL?
GOD DAMMITTTTTTTT
UHHHHHHHHHH HA
This can never be unseen
Sweden
Okay what's sexual about Sweden?
What in the JESUS FUCKING CHRIST is wrong with you guys!!!
What about a toilet?
Please god don't ruin toilets for me
OH MY FUCKING GOD!!!
THAT IS FUCKED UP, ALRIGHT!
OH MY GOD!
I'm not even gonna show that because you're not gonna be a--
You're not gonna be a happier person.
What about an iPad?
*laugh that sounds like a baseball bat to the throat*
What the fuck?
Why would you do that? Why?
THE PONY STUFF! IT'S SO FUCKING WEIRD!
What about math?
What're you fucking kidding me?
Guide to making Rule 34
Take a character
Likely underage from the 1980's
Jesus Christ
Remove clothing
Step 3: SPIT IN GOD'S EYE!
Well I couldn't have put it in a better way myself
What about a video game console?
*laughter*
There's the DS in the background too
Who the fuck had a two Dreamcasts?
Those shit were so expensive!
What about rule 34 itself?
oh my fucking god, people are fucking insane
oh my god
I can't do this shit anymore
I CAN'T DO THIS ANYMORE!
I'M DONE
YA'LL SICK
YA'LL SICK! NOW EXCUSE ME
I'M GOING TO BLEACH MY EYES
*MANY SCREAMS OF PAIN*
I'M BLIND
OKAY
BROS
Whatever you do
DON'T FLAG THIS VIDEO
It will all have been for nothing if you do
#2
I forgot
NUMBER #3: Like this video
Subscribe for more quality content like this
And join me on my path to madness
As always
Brofist!